Well, can I increase dosage on antioxidants to make them cancer-killing oxidants?
So anti-oxidant versus oxidant therapy and anti-oxidant is going to be something that is going
to help with oxidative stress.
So remember, any toxins that we're exposed to can be our sources of oxidative stress that
can then cause damage to our cell membranes, cause damage to the nucleus of the cell,
and can be a cause of cancer.
So oxidizing agents are typically not thought to be good.
Now understand, I've said this for 40 years in practice here almost, that everything is
about balance.
So you do need a certain amount of oxidative stress in your body, even if you don't have
cancer.
You need a certain amount of oxidative stress.
That oxidative stress will help you kill pathogens, so living organisms are killed through
oxidative stress.
They're also killed through an immune response, but they're also killed through oxidative
stress to kill a pathogen inside the cell.
Your immune system is not getting inside the cell.
You don't have macrophages intracellularly.
You don't have lymphocytes intracellularly.
What do you have intracellularly to kill pathogens that go inside the cell?
Well you have oxidative stress, so your body is making a certain amount of oxidants that
will then oxidate a pathogen and kill it.
Pathogen there readily killed through oxidation.
That's why most topical, like hydrogen peroxide, for example, via hydrogen peroxide, a great
topical killer of an infection.
You have a cut on your hand and you want to make sure it doesn't become infected.
You could put some hydrogen peroxide out of it.
Why?
Because it's an oxidizing agent and it will readily kill bacteria or viruses or a pathogen.
Let's try to enter through that break in the skin.
So it is in the cell, your cells are making oxidants as well as antioxidants.
It's all about balance.
The truth is that for most people that don't have cancer, most of us are exposed to more
oxidizing agents than our bodies have the ability to create antioxidants.
That can be a bad thing because that could be a cause of cancer.
Obviously, oxidizing agents are a major cause of cancer.
But once you have cancer, now the tables flip.
Cancer cells because they're rapidly replicating are already at a state of high oxidative stress
and we could understand that information and support the killing of the cell by tipping
it over by causing more oxidative stress.
So that's what this question is leading towards.
How do I increase my dosage of antioxidants to make them more cancer-killing oxidants?
And the question is asked because we've talked about dose-dependent vitamin C. So vitamin
C and a regular dose, let's say you're taking 500 to 1,500 to 2,000 milligrams of vitamin
C per day.
The benefits are it helps stimulate your immune system and it's a strong antioxidant.
But if you take vitamin C at a higher dose, the studies that are out there show higher
dose of, I'd say you have to be maybe 4,000 milligrams or 4 grams per dose, remember we talked
about, if you spread out, well, I take 4,000 milligrams a day, so I'm safe because then it's
more oxidative.
So when you get up to 4,000 milligrams, you would say that that's more an oxidative stress
therapy than it is an antioxidant therapy.
Still has the great stimulation of the immune response that we need as a cancer patient,
but we're hard to see that oxidative stress piece.
But as we shared last week, that if you spread that 4,000 milligrams out throughout the day,
now you're really only getting, let's say you're taking a four times a day, it's four hours
apart or something.
Now you could really only count 1,000 milligrams of that.
But now you're getting antioxidant effect.
So it is per dose, it's per, you know, every all supplements that you take, they're going
to have a half-life of your body.
So if at any given time in your body, you're only experiencing a maximum of 1,000 milligrams
and vitamin C, it's really going to function as an antioxidant, so you have to take it as
a one dose pill.
So how would you increase those things?
We shared the article that I shared about it and go back and look at the blog post that
says, Heart Acid Oxidate Distress, if you just go into our website and go to the search,
and start typing, Heart Acid, you'll come up with my blog post from the article that I wrote
about, Heart Acid Oxidative Stress Uncertain Nutrients to make them oxidants and help kill
cancer.
Vitamin C in a dose of about 4 grams per dose, vitamin E, it's not even all that much.
So if you're taking like A-POP-E, if you're taking even one of them is probably add a
dose and up to, to be an oxidizing agent, certainly to, selenium, I think I have it in that article.
I think it's 200 micrograms and selenium, I can't remember.
And then melatonin, melatonin is another one.
If you take it at a normal dosage, nobody's taking melatonin to be an antioxidant, but
it has some antioxidant qualities.
But if you take it at a high dose, so high dose melatonin for cancer, the reason why it works
is because it works as an oxidizing therapy, but you really have to be at least 40 milligrams.
So I'd say 40 milligrams in above would be an oxidizing therapy.
A few weeks ago on the Zoom, we were talking about being sure to increase the doses of
common antioxidants, like vitamin C, vitamin E, so that they will become oxidizers instead.
Should I be concerned about antioxidants that I'm adding to my smoothie, such as merinda
power powder, or adding Alma, or ashwaganda?
Well, yes and no, it depends on the strength of that antioxidant.
Yes, merinda has some great cancer-killing properties, but the dose that you're probably
taking it, it's not so much an antioxidant.
There's so many nutrients that have antioxidant properties understand.
So it's not a matter of eliminating all of them.
You're really looking at the strong antioxidants that you want to eliminate.
Now, I would say, obla is a pretty strong antioxidant, so you want to make sure you're taking an extra
scoop of that.
Ashwaganda, I would not say that's a strong one, I wouldn't worry about that.
There are strong antioxidants that I would say you should be careful about glutathione,
obviously, NAC, because that's a precursor to glutathione, alpha-lopeic acid, and vitamin
C. Those are your biggies that you'd really want to make sure you're careful with.